there's got to be another way truly
there's got to be another thing to do
with this dude he only killed
two people with a car
literally he killed like two people
there's gotta be
a better way to handle this situation
you know and i i don't know what it is
but i want we can can we write him a
letter we can write him a letter we
start composing the letter right now
okay
dear cameron
let's write him a letter let's see if
he's
doc here all right dear
dear cameron cameron
your story
moved me
i was a bad driver when i was young
have you ever masturbated while driving
lol you're not spelling it right dummy
i spelled masturbating wrong i think so
maybe not
pop up okay i think there's two ways to
spell it you can do it with the u also
have you ever mastered painted while
driving lol
i have
have you ever gotten road head
i would like to suck you in your car
while we drive around killing people
i know you are a good person and you
didn't mean it
what does your [ __ ] taste like
i hope you are finding god
this is very tough to write
can i visit you in prison
let's now read it back to me because i
want to make sure because i want it to
sound
good like i don't want it i obviously
want to i
i think it should be like appreciate the
gravity of the situation
but also you want to be sensitive but
right yeah
okay dear cameron your story moved me
i was a bad driver when i was young have
you ever masturbated while driving
lol i have have you ever gotten road
head
i would like to suck you in your car
while we drive around killing people
i know you are a good person and you
didn't mean it what does your [ __ ]
taste like
i hope you are finding god this is very
tough to write
can i visit you in prison it's not a bad
letter
like if because people need
people in jail i've spoke to some people
that have done a hard time
and what they really need is something
kind of like that motivates them
but also gives them perspective and i
think even though that's short
i think it it jumps around a little bit
and it gives them a few different things
to think about
save that i don't know that we'll send
it we're not gonna send it
he's i really do feel bad for the dude i
don't know what to
i don't know what to do it's very sad
right yeah
but if he wasn't good looking no one
would care i wouldn't care
no one would care but it is crazy when
you think about it
as somebody who is a bad driver like
you know it could have been me it could
have been you it could have been
anybody in
24 years it's a real moral question
you know should
insanely hot people be subject to the
same laws
that other i don't care if this kid
killed my
mother i would not
want him in jail truly i'm not even
if he killed my mother my father
my stepmother my aunts uncles
if he i'm telling you right now if this
guy
killed my entire family and most of my
friends except ben because i
we got to do this but if he killed
everyone i knew i would i would still
get on my knees
for him immediately and say and say
you know hey you you are
someone is that good looking they they
should
it is kind of a superpower you know
if the rich and famous don't go to
prison why should the heart
that's a good question no one's even
famous anymore really
i mean look at that face he makes with
the big eyes when he learns he's getting
24 years
it's brutal to watch
it's brutal he learns he's getting 24
years